at our community that don't have health
care no I didn't have health care
forever just let it go you know I got it
a week ago and I booked all the
appointments did you everything I got
the kittycat checked got the teeth
checked nice eyes were you worried about
the teeth you have the feeling like you
have a cavity like a some phantom cavity
like shit yeah how's my tooth hurt don't
have a fucking cavity I definitely did
my teeth were like crevices Oh Jeff
bunch cavities yeah she filled me like
four times because I haven't been
because health care is ridiculous no I
wasn't eating candy you got all these
holes in your face I don't know I think
like you know changes in my life maybe I
got ringworm from you yeah little kids
get her all the time they do
oh dude just rolling in dirt I'm gonna
blow your way blow your mind away okay
hookworm is was super common in the
south and it literally diminishes your
capacity for thinking so like the idea
like God Southern dumb person see oh no
sorry I didn't know she was gonna do
that
no not maybe people Theo knows he's
relative if you had to say they feel
godvoice like maybe a few people that I
know yes
yeah yeah there were all hookworm
victims what so how do you get hookworms
walking around barefoot ah I mean that
there's just too many opportunities to
get these worms in your body oh for sure
that's so gross look when you see dudes
who go to like some foreign country and
they get scratched and they come back on
botflies cologne other in their belly a
kid just died recently in India I think
it was India he got a infection he was
having headaches and it turns out worms
from pig feces had they made it all the
way up into his brain and they were
making cysts all throughout his brain
they said it was so bad they couldn't
even give him deworming medication
because if they did there were
his brain would start bleeding and that
you know he would suffer from a stroke
what I am NOT gonna sleep tonight all
it's warm talk it was a ten year
cirrhosis hold on they have pictures of
the dudes brain it's just like filled
with sis morning oh you know what I was
saying before I forgot to bring my fanny
pack you gave me one of your fanny packs
and I travel with that everywhere thank
you very much I'm glad you enjoy it it's
the most trying to spread the
resourceful thing this is my fanny pack
I know where this I have the same one
and a couple people have talked some
shit and I was like you better step back
step back step back she's got a pharmacy
in there I've got my whole thing so I
can be a doctor on the road scope I got
a scalpel what's up he complained of
having pain in his groin and swelling in
his eye and then they found out he had
cysts all over his brain I mean I have
pain in my groin every week but his
brain on the right I'm assuming as a
result both of its different views
they're both different views those
little holes are all cysts inside is
bronc his brain is literally imploding
although those little spots those little
white spots those are all little cysts
inside his brain that must have been
painful fucking pure agony it must be
pure act and this was in India you said
what country was man of India yeah you
know talk fuck that and just imagine
like people having not the access to
health care in this country but at least
we're a little bit modernized
being in one of those countries in being
poor you're fucked you're so fucked by
swallowing microscopic eggs passed in
the feces of a person who has intestinal
pork tapeworm by never going to brunch
again but think about that's not even
just pork tapeworm it's the eggs in the
shit of a person who has the tape did
you see what Jesus truly hell's get in
your mouth I'm sure I smoked a joint
before this shit I am in a pure panic
yeah don't eat ass in India unless that
person is on anti tapeworm medication
also never eat ass again I mean this is
a PSA for anti ass eating it is I told
you I had a cool I have few weeks ago
that was my life Hussein Jamie there's
been a change in the way that the pork
industry is gonna be doing inspections
that the government is gonna stop doing
it apparently as of like early May and
the industry is now taking over Oh
that'll be here that's just that's
exactly what you want this is one of
those things where people that are all
in favor of deregulating everything you
need to understand this shit like this
happens if these people cut corners and
we know people have cut corners before
maybe it's not all of them maybe most of
them are gonna be great people gonna die
sick they're gonna get ecole are they're
gonna get all sorts of fucked-up things
40% and replacing them with my god
cutting the number of federal inspectors
by about 40% that is such a bad idea
like America and everywhere is gonna get
a whole bunch of hookworms this is like
having the Mafia police the streets
since I'm taking away there would be no
less manslaughter line speeds oh that is
so gross no one's trying to make it
quick